i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below
we're going to start today in australia
where progressives scored a massive
victory in the australian elections
those were on saturday dozens of you
emailing me about this and saying david
you've got to cover what's happening in
australia because not only is it a
massive victory for the left it's also a
big signal about what could be possible
maybe
in the united states if the united
states became significantly less crazy
and we'll get to that in a moment
the liberal party in australia led by
the prime minister scott morrison wanted
a fourth term in a row
and the opposition the main opposition
the strongest opposition was the
left-wing labour party led by anthony
albanese
votes are still being counted but it
does appear as of this morning as though
the labour party will have the ability
to form a government due to some major
wins that they had and as of right now
and again they're still counting votes
these numbers may change as of this
morning i should say
this morning australia time
labor looks to be up to 73 seats
while the liberal party appears to have
lost 24 seats from 75 before the
election
down to only 51. this is a big
defeat for the centrist liberal party
and it is a crushing victory
for the left-wing labour party now also
of note the green party led by adam bant
appears to have secured three seats they
previously had one so gaining two from
one to three seats as of this morning
the green party although the final
numbers may change a little bit
so this would make anthony albanese the
fourth labor leader
and by the way i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly the fourth labor leader
to win control of the government since
world war ii
so the first question is how on earth
did labor achieve this what did they run
on well a huge component of labor's 2022
platform
was climate change
it was a platform of
renewal not revolution
and labor making a number of promises
along the lines of the environment and
dealing with climate change labor
promised to nearly double australia's
2030 target cuts to carbon emissions
saying let's cut by 43 percent by 2030
and be it completely net zero by 2050.
very ambitious is it possible to do that
well time will tell but they ran on it
and the voters liked it
transitioning to renewable energy
upgrade the nation's energy grid roll
out solar banks and community batteries
as many as many of you know
it's great that solar panels are
becoming more and more efficient but
you've got to be able to store that
energy to really increase the viability
of solar
at a larger level
the labor party said that they would
approve new coal mines
if they stack up environmentally and
economically so not saying we're not
doing any more fossil fuels but saying
it's it's really got to make sense in
context a promise to keep the uh
australian great barrier reef more
protected to protect endangered species
to do more about bush fire recovery and
also campaigned on increasing
australia's federal national minimum
wage more funding for child care centers
nursing homes and disability services
and understand that this is not
communism
this is not socialism there were right
wingers all over twitter and all over
truth central and all of these other
places
saying australia has gone completely
communist now the really funny thing is
the various many of the very same people
would say that the liberal party was
also communist now understand the the
this is true
what i would call left center left
you've got the center
you've got the center left which would
be like the liberal party like justin
trudeau in canada more or less that's
center left and then you've got this is
not far left this is what i would call
left center left it's social democracy
it's certainly to the left of biden and
justin trudeau but it is not socialism
and it is not communism it's basically
where i am it's social democracy in
something more or less approximating the
nordic model the northern european model
so
understand that many of the same people
that are now saying oh australia has
elected socialists
they say justin trudeau is a socialist
they said that the australian liberal
liberal party was also socialist when
they were not so these people you can't
really go to them this is going to be a
major experiment can labor
in power
get things done
and maybe even more importantly are the
things labor wants to do
actually viable will they work because
another big
criticism of many of the ideas that i
and other social democrats espouse is
that stuff would never work if you had
the opportunity to make it law to make
it policy to actually do this stuff it
will implode your country it will be a
disaster for your country well let's see
and depending on the level of
obstruction that's possible in australia
we may in a few years have some answers
do these ideas actually work despite
what the right loves to say when people
like me and others propose them in the
united states so it's going to be a
fascinating time and this is
we can't shortchange what this is this
is a massive victory
for the left
running on climate change
environmental justice economic justice
renewable energy all of these things
we've been talking about a couple of
notes
stephanie from australia wrote into me
and said quote
one of the most interesting aspects of
this has been a large number of very
wealthy traditionally liberal party
inner city districts
being taken by a group of loosely
aligned independents who are
economically moderate right but
pro-action on climate change political
integrity and gender equality this is
being seen as a repudiation of the
conservative government's move to the
right towards a more republican style
would an independent movement like that
with funding from rich moderate
conservative backers as this case here
have any chance in similar areas of the
u.s well the question in the u.s is
i don't know that we have that group
i mean i guess anecdotally there are
some
center-right moderates who are quite
socially liberal and pro-action on
climate change
but i don't really know that that's
really a big contingent i mean here you
know if you if you think of the center
right in the united states and i know
everybody this is fraught because people
would say those aren't really center
right people if you think of the center
right in the united states which is
people like joe manchin and mitt romney
they don't seem big
on taking bold action on climate
uh they seem to really want to kind of
just protect business interests when it
comes to thinking about climate so sure
stephanie it would work if we had that
contingent in the united states i don't
know that we do but i'm willing to have
my mind changed also our friend josh
zepps who uh i've been on his show i
don't remember if he's been on my show
he's australian he had a good tweet
quote the lesson of the australian
election is unambiguous if you refuse to
address a big problem that voters
persistently say they care about they'll
smack you down australians are fed up
with excuses about climate chaos they've
been saying this for years welcome to
democracy
hopeful results
in australia a really big deal all right
i have something amazing for you guys
within just a couple of weeks of the
leaked news
that the supreme court will soon be
overturning roe v wade
2022
house of representatives polling has
completely reversed and in a new npr pbs
marist national poll democrats are now
plus five over republicans
looking at the november congressional
elections now we're not going to go
crazy and get ahead of ourselves i'm not
going to start ripping apart my
microphone and burning it and
celebrating anything not that i would do
that anyway we're going to look through
this piece by piece and in order to do
that we have to first start with what
would we expect
in such a midterm
typically
in a midterm the party that is not in
the white house does well right now
democrats are in the white house joe
biden took the white house from trump in
2020 and so we would expect republicans
to do really well in the midterms now
let's look at some previous examples in
2018 after donald trump took power in
2016 democrats were plus seven in
polling going into the midterms and they
ended up plus eight in an aggregate of
congressional races okay trump wins
next midterm democrats plus seven eight
in the 2014 midterms after barack obama
won re-election republicans were plus
two and they ended up winning by almost
plus six
obama re-election republicans win okay
2010 barack obama had just won in 2008
over john mccain taking the white house
from republicans previously held by
george w bush obama wins 2008
2010 republicans were plus nine in the
midterms ended up plus seven in those
midterms disastrous midterms for
democrats okay so
normally these first midterms uh in
particular the first ones but even after
a democratic re-election you expect to
see republicans do well we now have a a
stunning new poll
these numbers you really have to see
them to believe them
47 percent of registered voters
now say they will support the democrat
on the ballot in this year's
congressional midterm while 42 say they
will back the republican that is plus
five for democrats
in advance of these midterms
now
we want to be thorough
we don't look at just one poll we look
at an average of recent polls and if you
look at the real clear politics average
of recent polls
you still have republicans plus two
looking at the generic congressional
vote now that is dramatically lower than
it has been
in any recent first midterm after the
party controlling the white house
changes power and it is declining
whereas republicans were polling about
an average of 48
in february
and about 47
in mid-march
and they peaked at uh 47 again in
mid-may
now
republicans are down from where they
were
could republicans still will win of
course of course it's still the most
likely scenario this is just one poll
but we are now seeing multiple polls in
an economist yougov poll democrats are
leading congressional vote generic in a
political morning consult poll democrats
are leading and yes in that recent npr
pbs marist poll i just mentioned
democrats are now plus five
what this means
is that the midterm might not be over
the impact of the roe v wade news
especially if and when it becomes
official
when the supreme court finally announces
its ruling
it could really give democrats a boost
and what it means at the individual
level is every one of us must vote
if you've ever voted before you should
vote
if you've ever thought about voting you
should vote if you've never voted you
should vote if you weren't old enough to
vote in 2020 but now you're old enough
to vote legally of course you should
vote if you've ever heard of voting like
if that's a concept you've ever heard
about you should vote because it doesn't
have to be the disaster that it was
shaping up to be
it seems as though the forthcoming roe v
wade decision
is absolutely uh hurting republicans one
other interesting note from that poll
which i think just should should be
mentioned
is on the question of overturning roe v
wade 64
of americans do not believe roe v wade
should be overturned basically by a
two-to-one margin two-thirds one-third
americans do not want the supreme court
to overturn roe v wade so if and when
that happens
it could be exactly the boost on which
democrats might be able to ride to okay
could it be victory in november maybe
but could it be a much much smaller loss
than what it was looking like three
months ago
that very much could be and as i've said
before
joe biden hasn't done that much to help
democrats in november
uh and we'll take all the help we can
get to get these republicans or keep
these wacky republicans out of power
if they want to hurt themselves by
virtue of their own supreme court picks
making a very unpopular decision when it
comes to roe v wade i'll take the help
from anybody we can get it uh anybody we
can get it from i guess i should say let
me know your thoughts let me know what
you make of this new polling and
remember that we are now just one week
away monday memorial day we will be
doing a one-day membership special all
you need to do to be notified is get on
my mailing list at davidpakman.com and
then on memorial day you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to avail
yourself
of this extraordinary membership
discount if you want to join today you
can do so at joinpacman.com we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this
of the fastest growing crimes in the u.s
is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below
so we're seeing increased concern uh not
yet panic but concern for now about the
spread of monkey pox possibly through
sexual contact which we're going to talk
about uh sort of as the second part of
this story so first of all what is
monkey pox monkey pox is an infectious
disease a communicable disease that uh
can be transmitted between animals and
people and also between people is caused
by the monkey pox virus the symptoms are
initially fever headache muscle pain
swollen lymph nodes and feeling tired
and then later you get this rash that
forms blisters which crust over and in
that sense it's in the kind of universe
of
smallpox chickenpox etc the type from
when you're exp the time from when
you're exposed until you get symptoms
is typically around 10 days which as you
can imagine
can make contact tracing potentially
more difficult
and the duration of symptoms is
typically two to four weeks it can look
a lot like chickenpox in humans and the
ways that it spreads unlike covid it
does not tend to spread through
aerosolized virus particles although
it's conceivable that if you have
respiratory involvement it could spread
in that way but primarily monkey pox
spreads through the handling of what's
called bush meat uh through being bit by
an animal uh or scratched by an animal
carrying it
and then between humans it can spread
through bodily fluids contaminated
objects close contact with other humans
who have it the smallpox vaccine
not the monkeypox vaccine the smallpox
vaccine is believed to be
about 85 percent effective at preventing
monkey pox and then in 2019 a monkey pox
vaccine called and i hope i'm
pronouncing this correctly janaeos also
known as
mvanex in the european union and
invimune in canada was approved for
adults in the united states so that's
monkey pox what's happening in this
particular outbreak earlier this month
several cases were identified in london
and one in northeast england portugal
and spain have reported several cases
and then a case was confirmed in
massachusetts by the cdc after a man
traveled to canada
potentially there's a case in new york
city that's under investigation and
health officials are investigating what
is believed to be florida's first
positive case it's a presumptive
positive case uh in south florida that
case appears to be related to
international travel and that person is
isolated um the canadian nexus is that
earlier this month in quebec two cases
were confirmed 20 more are still under
investigation in canada so how is it
spreading uh what's the connection here
the who right now is working on a sexual
contact theory this is very early we
don't have all the details but david
heyman
from the who spoke to reuters and is
working on the idea that
there seems to be a possible sexual
contact kind of chain
in a number of the cases so far
heyman said quote what seems to be
happening now is that it's got into the
population as a sexual form a genital
form and is being spread as a sexually
transmitted infection
uh which has amplified its transmission
around the world
very early um important things and
if you're wondering oh no
are there already conspiracy theories
about monkey pox yes there are and we're
going to get to the momentarily but if
you're wondering number one is this
likely to trigger a global covid type
response the answer is almost certainly
not this spreads differently it's less
contagious
and we're going to deal with that kind
of in the conspiracy segment
and number two is this strictly speaking
a sexually transmitted disease strictly
speaking it's not but it is a disease
that can be spread through sexual
contact uh and we're gonna have more
information about that as we continue to
learn about this but that's the latest
from uh uh the who and other authorities
on monkey pox
yes let's talk about the conspiracy
theories
should we be surprised that within hours
of learning about the monkey pox
outbreak that is being investigated
uh the usual suspects are already
promulgating and promoting conspiracy
theories no
we should not be surprised when all you
have is a hammer the hammer of we're
going to tell you who's really doing
this like the globalish globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron yeah
exactly it should not surprise us that
marjorie taylor greene and alex jones
and others are already ramping up with
the conspiracy theories marjorie taylor
greene is focusing in on bill gates bill
gates uh and his
uh remember early in covid the idea was
well bill gates through what looks like
just philanthropy
is um
trying to donate to vaccine development
to surreptitiously track people's
location
through vaccine microchips or whatever
okay here is marjorie taylor green on
bill gates and smallpox gates why is
bill gates running everything why does
he get to decide that you know bill
gates i want to remind everyone he wants
to grow fake meat in a petri dish and he
wants a peach tree what it says to drink
poop water so i don't know why we're
letting bill gates decide our health
decisions i didn't think we were here's
the deal uh bill gates is very concerned
about monkey pox because this is
something apparently he can make a lot
of money off of and him and his other
buddies but in the blue blue blue blue
state of massachusetts someone has
contracted monkey pox perhaps they got
it from canada from justin trudeau's
lovely country up there it doesn't
appear that the fact that there's a
canadian nexus has anything to do with
justin trudeau's politics it seems to
have to do with canadian travelers to
other countries but yeah
do we even care about the facts when
you've got a great story and then even
now they're reporting monkey pox cases
in sweden and italy
that is disgusting
and it is terrifying
nasty horrible big
bubbles of pus
on your skin i mean clearly nobody wants
this so they're going to have pictures
of all of these kind of terrifying
images they're going to show children
with this all over their faces and of
course they're going to be from i don't
know where they're going to be from and
then they're going to tell you you're
going to be from vile countries wear a
mask from because if you get close to
anyone's face and they spit on you
you're gonna contract this horrible
terrifying disease monkey pox but don't
worry you got to go ahead i know you
have a dr fouchy pillow that you sleep
with every night we need to order your
bill gates pillow you got to have you
should have a body pillow of bill gates
and you can cuddle with it every night
because bill gates is going to save the
day
very very sick woman now of course if
it's sexual contact that is the
mechanism for spread for monkey pox
primarily right now
it's not really clear that some kind of
full masking protocol is really what we
need now it is true that masks can help
prevent the spread of monkey pox if
there are respiratory elements but
monkey pox doesn't tend to spread via
what we would call small
respiratory droplets or aerosolized
respiratory droplets like covid now with
all of this they stuff she mentions bill
gates but who is always the they she
mentioned massachusetts so maybe she
thinks liberals in massachusetts are
going to be putting this stuff but it's
it's the the vague they obviously bill
gates isn't the one doing any of this
stuff and then we go to alex jones alex
jones insanely claims that it could be
the coveted vaccines that are causing
monkey pox and watch how he puts this
together
monkey pox pops up in
more than 20 countries all over europe
all over the u.s all over
everywhere where you have people taking
astrazeneca
astrazeneca
and jnj ladies and gentlemen
because what is astrozenica and j and j
right they're virus vectors that inject
the genome of a chimpanzee
into your cells and then orders your
cells to replicate under those orders
okay
so
the argument from alex jones here is
the jnj vaccine inserts a simian simeon
means of monkey uh provenance a simian
genome
and listen the word monkey is in monkey
pox after all
so therefore
published internationalist trotskyite
socialist yeah um
humans are mostly getting monkey pox
from other humans
so uh this is a completely hair brained
and completely free of evidence
conspiracy theory
but remember when the explanation for
everything is somebody who's lied to you
somebody who's done something to you a
government
globalist
which are disproportionately jewish men
when in all of these globalished
conspiracy theories it's it's jewish men
um
when you have those scapegoats
of course you're going to go to them so
we will be following the monkey pox
outbreak from a science perspective from
a perspective of empiricism and things
that we actually know and can say with
certitude um if you're just listening
today and you're morbidly curious about
the clips i played of marjorie taylor
green and alex jones you can find them
on our instagram page at david pakman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
let's talk about deceptive headlines
that can be written to achieve political
goals i hope that this segment is a good
snapshot of how headlines can be used to
distort and to influence and to
um push a particular narrative that may
be interesting to one media outlet
versus another so what happened well joe
biden was recently asked during his
current trip to asia
about chinese aggression towards taiwan
now that's a legitimate issue we've
talked about it on this program will
china see the chaos of what's happening
in ukraine thanks to the russian
invasion as maybe an opening
in which they could make a military move
against taiwan so china taiwan that's
the issue it's a real issue it's a
legitimate issue president joe biden was
asked about it and joe biden confirmed
if china invaded taiwan
um
the u.s would intervene and that's been
american policy for a long time so let's
look at the actual question and answer
this is the source material
for the topic and the subsequent
headlines we're going to look at you
didn't want to get involved in the
ukraine conflict militarily for obvious
reasons are you willing to get involved
militarily to defend taiwan if it comes
to that yes
you
are that's the commitment we made
okay so that's not news it's there's
nothing there that's actually newsworthy
there's something called the one china
policy
you can agree with the one china policy
or you can disagree with it but the
policy has been
dating all the way back to 1979 it was
first started uh stated in 1972 the u.s
acknowledges that china on either side
of the taiwan strait
maintain there is uh but one china and
that taiwan is a part of china that's
the united states position
now in 2016 donald trump said the u.s
isn't necessarily bound by the one china
policy and lots of people said oh my
goodness trump is trying to change the
one china policy but then in a phone
call in 2017 that trump had with
xi jinping they talked about a number of
different things and trump agreed at the
request of president xi to honor the one
china policy okay so we have that
we also have the taiwan relations act
from 1979 and we have the six assurances
as they're called that reagan gave to
taiwan in 1982 which say
that if taiwan violates the principles
the u.s
believes in
or if a rather if china violates the
principles that the u.s believes in the
u.s would help taiwan to defend itself
um if china were to invade the united
states would help taiwan in that
situation so this has been policy for a
really long time so biden is asked
during the press conference well if uh
china attacks would the u.s help defend
taiwan and the united states president
says yes that's the commitment we made
it's not news biden is essentially
saying
the stuff we've agreed to
for the last 40 years
we're going to abide by it that's it
that's the story
check out how every news corporation
media outlet covered it and by me by
news corp we mean fox fox business wall
street journal the wall street journal
titled their article
biden says us would intervene militarily
if china invaded taiwan fox news says
u.s military will defend taiwan if it
comes to that biden says
fox business segment
says biden says u.s will intervene if
china invades taiwan now again it's not
about these headlines being literally
false
it's the fact that they're being written
specifically to further the idea of
biden's out there looking for wars
biden's out there looking for military
conflict and it was trump who was
keeping us out of wars this has been the
narrative in the george w bush era the
right loved war they loved spreading
democracy and all of this different
stuff and then trump came in and trump
said the iraq war was a bad idea even
though previously trump had said i would
have gone into iraq doesn't matter trump
came in and said iraq was bad which is
true
uh just he's a hypocrite on it and he
said hillary will get us into wars but i
won't i'm gonna keep us out of wars and
get us out of more places and then the
claim made about joe biden was biden's
gonna get us into wars biden's
bloodthirsty biden's war hungry
even though there was no such evidence
of that
and so
they want to write headlines that will
further that and most of the fox
audience probably doesn't realize most
of the wall street journal audience
doesn't realize
the u.s has previously said
we would help to defend taiwan in such a
case biden's not
treading new ground here biden's not
changing policy he's not announcing new
policy but the story that fox wants to
tell is here's biden once again looking
for military problems so they'll say
look at biden wanting to intervene
look at biden wanting to interject and
inject the military the truth is biden's
saying i'm not changing the 40-year
policy that we've had now comparatively
reuters had a more straightforward
headline for the story reuters called it
no change in u.s policy towards taiwan
says white house official now it's not
only fox opting for the more salacious
headlines most of them do it cnn had a
similar one but it's at least more fair
cnn's headline was biden says u.s would
respond militarily if china attacked
taiwan
but white house insists there's no
policy change and indeed there isn't so
it's really important to understand how
to research these things directly if you
were uh to google one china policy
six assurances to taiwan
u.s relationship to china and taiwan you
would realize there's not a newsworthy
element here joe biden is just saying
like yeah this is the policy and we're
going to stick to the policy the story
is
biden doesn't unilaterally change
anything when it comes to china and
taiwan
that doesn't really make
for a very exciting headline so that's
the
genesis the oranges for lack of a better
term
of a bunch of these headlines and
hopefully instructive in understanding
how these narratives can be woven
this is a story that there was not a lot
of coverage of but it is very disturbing
an anti-vaccine
anti-gay street preacher has reportedly
killed his own wife
because god told him to this is a wacky
wacky story
an anti-vaccine street preacher
has been arrested for allegedly killing
his own wife and allegedly admitting it
so there's not too much doubt here but
we're still being legally careful
the victim is a 25 year old kansas woman
named regan marek
she previously played goalie for the
kansas university women's soccer team at
the time her name was regan gibbs on the
team roster her husband is 26 year old
chad merrick suggesting merrick is her
married last name according to police
chad merrick called 9-1-1 on himself
after this incident the wife was dead
when emergency crews arrived tragic and
disturbing story
the suspect was one of these street
preachers who get a bullhorn and they do
religious stuff in populated areas and
talk about jesus he would also post
videos online which i'm not going to be
playing today and in those videos he
would attack covet vaccines as spreading
the spirit of the antichrist he would
warn people that they are coming from
your children who is the they well he
would also warn that the lgbtq agenda is
coming for your children so seemingly
that's what he means he allegedly told
police
god told him
to kill his wife
quote from fox 4's charade honeycutt he
called police and said he has killed his
wife did he possibly say why he may have
done that
and a police representative said quote
he told us
that god told him to do it so this is
one of those cases where you know when
we talk about the uh
the buffalo shooter from now close to
roughly two weeks ago a week and a half
ago
um
the right very quickly jumped to
this is just a mentally ill person
completely disconnected from politics in
all ways just there's nothing political
here
doesn't pass the sniff test we look at
the manifesto from the buffalo shooter
and we see that it's cogent fascism
it is
very much
a seemingly coherently
parroting and mirroring
the substance of the great replacement
theory etc stuff that we've seen
parroted by people like tucker carlson
on fox news and others and yes to some
degree we can also say well most
mentally ill people never commit
violence and lots of people believe
things that are wrong there's an
additional element here
which certainly um could be a factor
nobody's denying that but we can't
ignore the very real kind of political
basis for the crime at least in terms of
the beliefs
in this case
this was an anti-vaxx pastor preacher i
guess preacher is the right word an
anti-gay preacher etc
but it seems very secondary to this
particular crime god told me to kill my
own wife
this case to create a contrast is the
point
it seems way more plausible to say the
main thing here
was some form of mental illness now of
course it's we're diagnosing from a
distance or not really not really
diagnosing but we're evaluating and
speculating from a distance in both
cases we would need to know more and
have more first-hand knowledge but the
point here is to say
when we cover up an incident by saying
it's only mental illness
we often intuitively say it doesn't
really make sense here these are the
perfect contrasts when we say well
mental illness for the buffalo shooter
very specific politically charged and
cogent manifesto
mental illness there has a very
obviously different meaning than in this
particular case where a guy allegedly
killed his wife because god told him to
not saying that there aren't multiple
factors to all of these stories but it
should at least allow us to see
how different the meaning of mental
illness can or might be in different
stories let me know if you agree with
the distinction i'm drawing here
in what are admittedly
tragic events
and very complicated events to
understand let me know your thoughts
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show
okay let's look at a couple of clips you
know something kind of interesting has
started happening over roughly i'd say
the last three to four weeks and it
relates to this guy mike lindell the ceo
of mypillow a right-wing pillow
manufacturer who became friendly with
trump early in the pandemic started
showing up about how he's going to be
making masks and all these things i
don't know that they ever made any masks
but really since the election pillow as
we know him pillow's goal has been to
overturn the election results insisting
dozens of times that we're just days
away we're weeks away maybe at the most
a few months away from blockbuster
evidence coming out and just overturning
everything and they're uh you know he he
claims that they're suing all machines
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines all of my coffee
machines are now in witness protection
as a result of that so anyway this this
thing has happened where
clearly pillow is a laughing stock and
we all recognize that but over the last
three to four weeks for me and i know
also for some people in the audience
it started to get almost a little bit
sad where the guy seems kind of
genuinely unwell in a way
and we know he has a background of uh
drug addiction in his past
and generally speaking it from things
that he said we're putting together that
he seems to really believe this crazy
election stuff
he is spending a ton of money and not
even really seeing his family going all
around the country pushing it
and i and some others in the audience
have started to wonder
whether this is kind of becoming
almost more
medical in nature in some way
and then all of a sudden over the
weekend uh pillow spoke at the
experience the reawakening reawaken
america tour this is the event where
like eric trump will often speak at it
and sometimes i think ted nugent has
spoken we're going to look at some eric
trump clips a little bit later
and um
pillow now seems to have a very bad hand
tremor so i'm going to play this clip
for you it is visual you sort of hear
the tremor in his voice a little bit but
really what you have to see is he starts
switching the mic from hand to hand
because the mic itself is shaking and a
lot of people emailed me about this and
listen i mean something does seem to be
going on with the guy
let's take a look
thank you all
you guys keep me going i'll tell you
that
we're not giving up than anything ever
so there you can see in the left hand
this is the key moment where the the
hand is just very very shaky when the
mic is in this hand
and then he seems to recognize it and
change the mic to the other hand so
uh and it's still shocking what he was
what uh clay was talking about there and
i pray for everyone he was just talking
about um the um there was the interview
over next door and uh
the guy uh all of a sudden they're
interviewing and i'm trying to tell him
what's going to happen like i do
all the media and once again he took it
down a road here and made it about
something it wasn't and i ended the
interview very abruptly um now
understand that what he's saying also
does it's just completely incoherent
and it wasn't and and you guys got to
realize normally that hand is just all
over the place i don't do that but i had
to get out here to speak
um normally i would sit there on the
phone with the media
for an hour hours at a time you could
call i have every media outlet i think
in my pocket from jimmykoska to uh
so anyway
it's it's something seems to be going on
here there seems to be some kind of
spiral happening and and it is getting
kind of sad i mean he has prior drug
issues we don't know anything about
what's going on right now who knows what
it could be and this isn't to make fun
of a medical condition nor a drug
addiction if either or both are factors
it's a reminder that this guy who has
been saying outrageous and untrue things
for over a year now about the 2020
election
corrosive
spending his money in a way that is
corrosive to democracy making also
throwing all sorts of innocent victims
under the bus
and we'll talk on the bonus show today
about how his count counter suits
against the voting machine companies
have been thrown out he's been doing a
lot of damage and he might genuinely be
unwell it's not an excuse for his
behavior but there's something sad about
watching him he does seem to genuinely
believe what he's saying and one one
wonders are there friends and family
here that could stage some kind of an
intervention because quite frankly this
doesn't seem to be good for him it
doesn't seem to be good for his family
which he claims he doesn't see anymore
and it's certainly not good for the
country um one other clip uh i want to
play from from pillow from over the
weekend this was at a different event
he is also claiming that the january 6
trump riots were set up by the left to
de-platform trump and his supporters
from social media and that it's
basically becoming nazi germany here
take a look then they took them both
because they had a safety net and what
was that that was january 6. they had
that all set up so that what would
happen would be a historical day in
history which was january 7th
and on january 7th is the day they tried
to take our voice forever they tried to
turn out the lights on all of your
voices
1.2 million americans were de-platformed
including our great president donald
trump on vimeo youtube sucker bucks
facebook twitter
vimeo you name it all these platforms
were you were cancelled
well that was the day
that they and i put fear into everyone
it was just like nazi germany where
everybody either had fear
or you sat over here and you didn't want
to talk about it you know you didn't
want to talk out of fear and everybody
you know um
when the trump rioters committed all
that violence and destruction of
property
and then trump was banned from twitter
it didn't strike me like nazi germany
and i'm curious how many of you say you
know but the first thing my mind went to
was nazi germany
i don't think so and uh you might have
noticed oh this is an interesting detail
in the background you might see that
there's a bus and on the side it says
jesus guns and babies jesus guns and
babies and this was at a campaign
in forsyth georgia for some of the
upcoming
elections happening there this is
obviously very sad when it comes to
pillow himself
but we can't ignore that there's an
extraordinarily dangerous movement here
and so when we when we talk about these
issues
we want to find kind of a
reasonable medium where we don't say
this is just political disagreement with
people who are completely of sound mind
because many of them don't appear to be
of sound mind on the other hand we can't
say this is merely a mental health issue
most people who have mental health
issues
don't do any of this stuff and so
we're trying to craft a more accurate
but also empathetic narrative
about what is a really scary and
unhinged movement that is sadly much
bigger than any of us would like to
admit but we have to be accurate and we
have to admit it's a pretty big movement
here in the united states i want to look
at one more clip from this reawaken
america thing as many of you know
donald trump is not a religious guy
donald trump is not a spiritual guy
donald trump has had out of necessity
because he was running as a republican
to start kind of pretending to be
religious when he wanted to become the
republican nominee and so he started
saying that the bible is his favorite
book up there
with the the book he wrote which he
didn't even really write he had a
ghostwriter but fine with his own book
the art of the deal and he would try to
tell little anecdotes about two
corinthians and this type of thing
um but when he was asked like what's
your favorite bible verse he didn't even
have an answer he said well it's too
personal i don't even want to talk about
it he now has found a very spiritual of
spiritual opposition to abortion as many
of you know all of this stuff is
completely contrived there's nothing
spiritual at all about donald trump and
quite frankly i don't think there is
about his kids either
but eric trump in particular has really
been playing up the religious thing i
think it might be because eric trump is
kind of the most dim-witted one don jr
has
his whole thing that he's used to get
attention ivanka is less interested in
being in the spotlight and anyway she
converted to judaism and there's a lot
of anti-semitism on the right so it's
not like she's gonna necessarily play up
a religion but eric trump's niche has
been
playing up his religiosity playing up
his spirituality and going to events
like the overtly religious
reawaken america tour so he spoke over
the weekend and he made the claim that
he makes his four-year-old say the
pledge of allegiance every night along
with some prayers
and he mentions in this the anti-antifa
code of destruction which is not not a
text i'm familiar with check this out if
this is real it's horrible and if he's
lying it's horrible that it's the type
of thing that would help ingratiate him
with the audience take a look and
literally the second week i'm there i've
got a little four-year-old luke he comes
home from school and we say prayers
every night together right we have these
little three kind of family prayers that
we say and the lord's prayer to others
okay do any of us believe that every
night eric trump and his four-year-old
say three prayers like
i don't know if they do it's fine but i
just have a very hard time believing
that but now we go into the pledge of
allegiance let's make him stand up put
his hand on his heart and do the pledge
of allegiance
and so i go luke i'm going to teach you
the pledge of allegiance tonight and he
goes oh dad i pledge allegiance to the
flag in the united states he does the
whole thing and i go you know in new
york they would have taught him the
antifa code
of destruction right like literally
anybody know what that is the antifa
code of destruction that that's not a
that's not something i've ever heard of
they're not doing the pledge of
allegiance in new york that much i can
tell you but
why is it that we have this war on the
flag on red white and blue why is it
that we have this war on the pledge of
allegiance why is it that you have
people tearing down
statues of our historical figures why is
it that
you know like they want to rewrite
the governing documents of of this
country they're trying to change history
they're trying to change some of the
greatest
fake he doesn't even know what the hell
he's talking about so
if it's true that he forces the pledge
of allegiance onto his four-year-old
every night it's horrifying if it's a
lie it's horrifying that it's the type
of thing he thinks would convince people
in the audience to like him and i sort
of suspect this isn't really happening
i'm not really thinking that donald ever
uh tucked eric trump into bed at night
uh and it seems to me like not exactly
the type of family that would really uh
be doing this at night that that's just
my instinct but it is an absolutely
fascinating family in that sense i do
feel bad for those kids and the pledge
of allegiance does feel really
antiquated i remember when i first moved
to the united states
it i think it was in first grade we were
i was introduced to the pledge of
allegiance and it always struck me as a
little bit weird
and what i always did was i would mouth
the words to look like i was
participating you know peer pressure i
was a kid but i wouldn't actually say
them because it felt so cringy and
creepy and bizarre
and then i don't know i have like a i
have the memory that it just kind of
stopped i don't know if it might have
been that in middle school the pledge of
allegiance instead of being done at the
classroom level was done like over the
loudspeaker where the whole school would
do it but then it just faded out i don't
know if it was while i was in middle
school or maybe when i went to high
school it's not really clear
um but uh it's a strange thing to be
doing in school
and it seems bizarre to be doing it
every night before going to bed i don't
even believe he's actually doing it it's
worse if he's doing it but i don't even
believe that he's actually doing it let
me know what you think we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p here's another viewer
who has a parent that they are
struggling with when it comes to
politics and media but this is a little
bit of a different problem than one
we've heard before take a listen to this
david
i know you get these calls all the time
yeah how do i get my mother off of fox
news
i mean she's not so radical that she
believes in chewing on and all this
other crazy crap but i can't get her to
turn off fox news
it's just insane man i mean as soon as i
leave the house she turns the [ __ ] on
i mean
anyway
i try to point out to her you know how
wrong they are
and then you know things happen i go
remember i told you they were wrong
about that and you know and i told her i
said see i'm i'm right about 90 of stuff
and fox news is wrong about 90 of stuff
but i can't get her to turn it off
anyway
thanks love you so man you do a great
job thank you well so listen this this
is tough persistent fox news watching
can be a hard habit to break or a hard
addiction to break
one of the things i would suggest
because it sounds like your mom is
really pretty deep into it
instead of immediately trying to get her
off of fox what i would suggest is just
that she diversify the media diet often
times with these situations
you want to take the path of least
resistance and the path of least
resistance initially might be saying hey
don't go after her and say never watch
fox news again but it might be
add this or that to your media diet
check out the pbs newshour or maybe
watch you know what get more variety in
your media diet maybe read something
would be an interesting one as well
though not not everybody reads
consider that the first step and you
know think about it like someone who's
addicted to uh i don't know imagine
someone every morning has one of those
sugary uh toaster strudels i don't even
know if those are around but i remember
when i was a kid that was like the
epitome or like a pop-tart or something
okay
and please if you work for those
companies don't sue me i'm just saying
they have a lot of sugar imagine someone
every single day has a toaster strudel
with extra powdered sugar and maple
syrup and all this stuff on it's like
okay that's really bad but if we just go
in and we say just stop just stop cold
turkey no more toaster strudels you can
understand how it'd be very difficult to
get that person to say okay sure no more
toaster strudels what do they replace it
with so if that was what i was dealing
with i might first go in and go hey you
know what
um
it might be interesting just for
diversity you know to try different
things if one morning a week instead of
the toaster strudel you instead get a
piece of beautiful multi-grain toast
and then spread some avocado on it with
some spicy chili oil
oh okay well now we've got an
alternative you're not saying drop the
toaster strudel you're saying have six
toaster strudels a week and have one
piece of avocado toast and then if that
goes okay you go hey you know what
there's so many great breakfasts
what if one morning you had a bowl of
greek yogurt with sliced up berries and
a no sugar granola it's delicious so now
you've got five to and then later you
can go hey you know it's how are you
feeling by the way you
you feeling any better now that you're
introducing some other and you get the
point okay so this is the same thing i
would suggest with fox news i would say
hey you know there's so many different
media outlets out there variety is good
what if one morning you listen to npr's
fresh air instead of watching fox and
friends or whatever the case may be
start there
and then see where that gets you and you
know
uh it's an uphill battle for sure but
that's probably with someone who's
really addicted that's probably where i
would start we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today as i mentioned
earlier a judge has dismissed mike
pillow's countersuits against smartmatic
and dominion voting machine
manufacturers
and
we are going to talk about what's going
on pillow is also being asked to pay
smart maddox attorneys fees which is
just beautiful republicans are vowing to
kill the domestic terrorism bill
currently being discussed in the senate
why i'll tell you and an archbishop
of the catholic church is barring nancy
pelosi from receiving communion because
of her support for abortion rights we've
talked before
about catholic elected officials and
abortion and communion in the context of
joe biden
we will also talk about it today in the
context of nancy pelosi get instant
access and i do mean instant by signing
up for the bonus show at joinpackman.com
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad thank you alex
and also if you would like a discount
off of the cost of a membership get on
my newsletter at davidpakman.com
you will thus get an email on monday
memorial day telling you how to take
advantage of a beautiful membership
discount see you then or tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below